see there we go
tournament started out of nowhere I'm
gonna take that's actually a bad move
that I just went with now I'll go with
this so fantasy land I should have maybe
just pushed now I'm going to push and we
have after all this a French going to
reinforce my d4 pawn castle castle and
then one night here is a threat I think
right pick up the dark Strava ship now
this is going to be brutal
actually I just get the bishop for free
dot I take this I'm going to be on the
Queen twice double-check so to speak on
that Queen I'm grabbing this pawn
jump in here pawn push bishop check okay
I should be okay with this I'm not going
to take this is a mate threat oh man
this is actually still working this is
kind of cool that's a cool mate the
knight had a block on e7 - two -
twenty-nine minutes remain ton of time
um okay
stay focused here stay focused take now
you're not I gave this advance in with
tempo start pushing my opponent around a
little bit okay structural change if
Knight here I'm not doing that okay
we're down a piece and now this night is
out of the ballgame he's not going out
of the ballgame he had to go to a3 i
takes bishop
okay Queen was doing something what was
she doing she was threatening my bishop
okay I want to get in h6 that coin out
of there okay
pieces are falling I have three minor
pieces here no matter what this game is
not going to finish you have this pawn
drop back here and everything I could
have taken the rook get out of there
they really going to take that bishop
they are okay looking for me f2 stuff I
want to maintain my Knights position
push this pawn down get rid of that rook
push my pawn get rid of their f2 pawn
actually forget about f2 let me grab
this guy everything is glued together
now they resigned back determined six a
bunch of sixes and some twos 78 players
at this point 18:38 is the average
rating more people could enter during
the tournament here we go okay I'm
dropping back I'm in third right now
three-way tie four five six way tie this
is one of them this is a big game right
here a very big game Sicilian and let's
see if I could get that night okay I'm
going to go with this structure and try
and play against their light square
Bishop and I think I'll be successful
with that now after this last move I
could get on these dark squares this is
just winning that pawn this Bishop is
not really around at all to get rid of
my knight Castle pawn push sword Queen
here first Queen here Knight takes was a
threat let me kick that night away kick
that night away and then develop my
Bishop captured the pawn and get my
Queen off of this file
and do what next keep my up there I also
take that okay I could get that dark
square Bishop let's do that take that
dark square bishop
I don't even sure what that move is
doing I shouldn't I could have a fork
now it's a threat of a fork I have it
this F 1 square is covered pawn push
there's got to be some meat coming up
let's check Oh
what am i doing the night blocks okay
this is this is silly
this was silly I have everything
defended don't I just push my pawn a
couple times just to drop back Bishop is
threatening me there my rook doing
something they don't have any time
anything they don't have any time I
should have done something better it
seemed I was holding my breath on that
one okay the tie for 12 tie for the 12s
there T Knight is up there the 12 okay
f3 doesn't help it just hurts it opens
up this diagonal now how it's not so
easy to Castle any more nights going to
try to kick my bishop away I just back
up the bishop checks okay I could just
block throw question the bishop over
here actually I dropped that pond so I
want to keep my light square Bishop
Brown actually on second thought Bishop
here would have been good I would have
given up the exchange if that were the
case
Bishop here is still good I want to kick
this night away now my king should be
quite alright here
Queen check I just block induced dark
square weaknesses get on this Square and
then may Queen moves okay actually the
knight is there to defend but if the
knight now moves it's going to be game
over bishop here remove the knight and
give me remove the night and then give
me on b2 okay my opponents doing a good
job to do what to get rid of that pawn
with check it's actually okay to do that
or is it no it's going to open up the a
file but okay let me just make sure
there's none of that bishop
made thread on this square dark square
weaknesses it's the big deal right there
big big deal
take this pawn it's going to be made on
this a1 square even after a queen trade
even after a queen trade this rook is
coming down to give me back to
tournament 20s and a bunch of 12s
anybody's game who is up there right now
for sure okay
22 minutes remain oh okay let's go after
this let's go after that square okay I
picked up a pond and get this guy out
castle f4 f4
yes let's open things up okay no
opposite sides castling so I can just
take your pin the night you jump my
knight in to dd5 Queen d2 just double up
this Knight out of here I'm covering
this square jump in here with tempo and
now the structure is going to be blasted
open maybe a fork got the Queen the rook
and now the night Queen versus Knight
position I'm going to resign pawn push
Knight see for Queen f1 picks it off
just trade trade rooks and watch out for
the knife Forks okay
this pond is going to march we probably
a maid there that I just missed okay 30s
and a bunch of there are three 30s and
20s in some 18 s 21 minutes remaining
okay beat me to the punch right there
all right let's take that developing
with tempo let's get on this diagonal
throw a question that guy maybe I could
have considered just pawn push right
there let's do it now
I want to pick up that dark square
bishop not just yet though he's not
going anywhere
or is he let's do that right now
get these pawns going establish a pond
here this Knight is pinned I'm going to
take that and then take this night
before he kills me on f6 okay I just
want to trade there's no tricky nights
around Queen trade yes
so my king wants to jump up on the dark
squares pawn push I just play here
mm-hmm
I'll do this pawn push are out rook up
right now it's my king down okay this is
the pawn bro pawn push to get my King
even further involved I don't know if
this is the best technique actually this
pawn is an issue there we go
open this up here my king is still good
now I have pawns here a little scary I
have this check man
my king is doing a really really good
job okay it's close to me okay now their
King is in trouble how the tables turn
how those tables turn I get that pond
okay get my king out of the way and push
my pond finally now let's get this pond
pushing anything whoa they were flying
at the end they're down at I'm 42 42 40
30s oh the sleepy sleepy hippo is here I
ever take that square we're going to try
I want to control a five control a five
is the plan my opponent is able to get
control over that then I could be in
some trouble so that's why I captured
with the pond and get my Bishop on f3
maybe push here soon it's a little scary
with the bishop coming out there
centralized my pieces keep my Queen over
here to guard some dark squares Oh
dropping this darn it and my opponent
wasn't taking it I'm tethered to the
defense of that okay is that night just
gonna go there
okay might be my saving this somehow not
really they have everything on this
square let's try this I'm dropping my
queen oh my goodness I dropped the head
out a moment to drop to get my queen
we're gonna take this I can't take that
one that one's pinned oh my goodness wow
they had an opportunity for my clean for
my clean Oh No tricky Knight
it's so easy to fall for a fork here
King position there's the fork ah man
oh this one's dead I can't save this is
there going to be a stalemate
there's no stalemate I only have one
second I got to resign
oh I'm down on time as well oh I dropped
back Oh John man's up there too you
should be commentating what are you
doing again oh that tricky tricky fork
will get you every time
it doesn't help because I pointed out
either if you'll know just because I say
you gotta watch out for the fork it
doesn't help me at all not one bit
not one bit okay so I have to go into a
mode that is more aggressive than what
I'm used to that is more aggressive than
what I'm used to so I'm going to try and
be clever here try to be clever see how
that works let's see how that works
let's just see about that
I got main to threat it's working that's
a sort of a quick kill are they gonna
resign oh don't be a clock burner ok
good back to charming 70 ok it actually
feels a little bit good to play catch-up
I feel a little this is the sleepy hippo
the sleepy hippo was the one that beat
me up he's the one that should have had
my queen maybe I was lucky to even
prolong that game Wow Wow
I gotta get the sleepy hippo man I had
this sleepy hippo man oh let's go okay
give me that give me that dark square
Bishop I get that dark square bishop
no I can't the sleepy hippo man the
sleepy hippo okay here we go I get this
pond advance in shot my night in here
and hit my opponent with the four can I
hit my opponent on a fork yes finally
okay can I convert this please I need to
kill this night before he kills me okay
he's dead at least I can't get work now
at least I can't get forked by the hippo
here we go back the tournament tied for
first 70s ah 15 were at the halfway
point okay here we go man I had to play
him to a two out of the last three games
that's not the guy you want to see after
you've lost him just a couple couple
games from then whoa whoa whoa whoa what
are you crazy
that was almost the craziest move ever
Wow the night would have killed me right
there would have killed me
what am i doing oh okay I know what I'm
doing
should take him my queen I got this
you're really gonna take that pun
shouldn't actually he's dead that's good
it's good okay so do I take him right
away no no need to take him right away
he's not going anywhere I don't have to
worry about the h-file now I'll take him
I'll try to take him I'll try to take
him watch out for over here no don't you
dare centralize my night
let's get over here towards their king
let's play over here towards their king
see how they like being attacked jump
right in here good dark square on the
rook should've just taken that pond okay
a little a little scary over here gotta
watch out for made on each seven watch
out for that made on each seven guard
these dark squares now there's nothing
now there's nothing once my opponents
threats are parried then then what what
am I trying to say okay I want to get to
be two that's what I'm trying to do b2
b2 is unavoidable
that's me back to Turman eighty eight
ninety four ninety eighty eight eighty
eight thirteen minutes remaining here we
go
the knighted Magi I killed this Knight
no I can't I'm going to take him okay
let's try and open them position up I
have a lead in development that's if
there's any compensation for me giving
up that the bishop pair it's a lead in
development let's see if this does
anything great okay you can't take my
queen just yet not just yet keep the
Queen's on the board
target that Queen could take if pawn
push
and do what next
okay can I grab that night okay this is
this is rook up and over stuff okay rook
right here as well turning this point
rook is in a pin but just going to be
defended or not is that a slight mouse
slip or something I don't know
110 108 92 ah less than 12 minutes
remaining I got a catch
top dog there 110 now let's not take
their let's not and say we did on that
one to keep this tension maybe even do
what let's take here a better castle at
night really going to move pawn push
here okay that night can't jump in here
just yet pawn push here and then I want
to play in the center if there's that
structural change keep this the knight
is going in Reverse isn't he
opposite to clean get off of that file
could drop my bishop back here pawn push
is where I want to be need to open this
up so this pod could maybe move this
night is going to have a really good
square though right here a really good
square the knight moves maybe this could
be a target on push I need a flight
square
let's get that get that night I way out
of there pawn push next pawn is running
fast to keep him going to fork Wow you
go fast right there he went fast they're
going to resign 10 seconds less than 10
I'm getting a rook they letting their
clock tick
no they resigned back determined I
believe 128 of just barely 128 110 108
10 minute warning
10 minute warning Caro okay
and that has to run away and we've been
here before by transposition in another
game this French I Bishop out my knight
here okay that only helps me build my
center right here actually bishop there
might have been good now I actually I
thought it would be trapping the Queen
it's not where is that mate making to
threat my knight is defended would it
really be taken Queen h5 is the threat
not really good solution to that just
move
h7 that's game back to tournament 148
131 12 9 minutes remaining
sorta okay alright so I want to focus on
that d4 square my Knights going to go
for a hike it's going to go for a little
journey a little journey right here the
weakest point in the white position and
now I want to get in this b5 advance I
got I want to play against b2 and I
could I want to I want to I want to
crash through on that soon Knight jump
isn't here actually this is going to be
maybe the knight is trapped now after
that last move can't go back to this
square I didn't realize that I realized
it too late well actually not too late
but she realized it sooner
b3 the knight doesn't have any squares
now f4 taken away of course 30 seconds
there's no good solution here just take
jump in here and try and take over these
dark squares get my my bishop
let's just take this pawn drop back not
all the way oh man can I get rid of that
light square bishop he's very annoying
okay get rid of that and that's where I
wanted to go that's where I wanted to go
broke up and then here keep everything
supported or defended f7 in particular
oh that could be taken now it should be
alright still it's a little scary
scarier than I would have liked but I
still have everything covered there down
on time back determent 168 150 150
something 7 minutes remaining
okay ah let's get my night out and get
castled get my bishop pending the night
and then I'm going to try and pile up on
them this advance is coming in however
now it can't come in it's not there in
time might have b5 I want to maintain
the pin and be annoying I might want to
sack if this I'm going to sack and then
try for f4 ok get this guy out of there
ok now I'm not going to have that sack
anymore let's get my knight doing
something else my knight wants to be on
this square my knight wants to be right
here my bishop strapped still trapped
with G but it's very weakening ok my
knight is just ready to land some
devastating fork or deliver mate with
Queen g3 Queen g7 main threat this pawn
is pinned pawn push I could just take
I'm going to take that this is leading
to mate no matter what matter where the
king goes Queen g7 is TKO back to
tournament 188 181 71 42 6 minutes
remaining
oh man okay here we go 6 minutes 16
seconds trying for f7 okay
can you temple on the Bishop Bishop b5
Bishop d6 night here okay I took that
first and let's just get that guy out of
there my bishop pinning their night and
their night but my queen up get my rook
on II keep that pin I'm gonna go all the
way back here pawn push yeah let's get
that in I was like I couldn't do that in
between takes
right away Knight takes here's available
on that night just get them out of the
way f4 seems appealing let's take this
first though night here Queen here and
then it's mate maybe Queen here it's me
might be very tempting that's me back to
tournament 208 208 171 62 five minutes
remaining
you have to forgive the clearing of my
throat there occasionally that granola
bar is never too far off okay
pass exchanges here mats exchanges okay
King up and no need to castle I don't
think my king is going to be vulnerable
or is he just make sure let's just make
sure my night is a bit unsafe here okay
I'm going to have dark square control
let's get these puns going oh you know
what okay now I could give a check after
pawn push port detail otherwise I'd be
dropping my beep on so I could take
first this is going to be lights out
it's winning everything it's a full rook
back to tournament they resigned 228 186
4 minutes remaining
okay John Madden oh my goodness John
Madden whoa what does John Madden do
that's a weak Square already I want to
trade light square bishop I want to
trade light square bishop
okay I'm getting material here they're
not gonna um winning and winning a lot
of stuff now gonna take right here you
can't get out of that pin so easily
right not the easiest pin to get out of
I take that might be but oh just do this
finish my development that rook is close
to dead that rook is dead okay let's
just get here time situation is fine
time situation is fine get my clean in
here hitting the night hitting the pond
give check okay
check
where's the main where does that mate
can I get rid of that night finally they
resigned back to chairman 248 248 206
192 22 ok d 4 d 4 why am I going with D
four okay French this is the last game
for sure well no not for sure but at
least this game has to be finished I
think I guess you have to watch out a
little bit with the lag Bishop g5 my
coin is close to being dead close is not
good enough I want to get to this dark
square but that's not so easily
accomplished my ponen is able to castle
in time or castle down opposite points
change this Queen away look up and over
seems a bit caveman like a little bit
caveman like why did I open up that
diagonal for that bishop actually I
didn't do that just yet let's go here
first
Queen checks get this pawn that's where
I want to be target this pawn you take
my knight
Pond push I should be doing we're about
even with time here ready to take the
night again oh oh that's with check this
is leading to matin to pawn push right
here that's happened a few times already
getting that Queen there once in this
term and I think in the previous one as
well this these ponds that are on rook 3
are giant thorns my opponents letting
their clock tick apparently less than 5
4 3 they called it game aboard it didn't
finish close all right close to forty
eight to twenty six 196 188 all right
good games all okay